[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
patrick kanner président du groupe
socialiste au sénat est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation donc au nom de public sénat
des échos de radio classique et de la fp
médias représentés ce soir par stéphanie
le rouge et lucile bréau bonsoir mes
demoiselles dans trois grandes questions
pour vous monsieur camair ce soir est-ce
que emmanuel macron a remporté le match
sociale qui lui permettra bien sûr
d'avancé sur d'autres réformes de le ps
peut-il renaître à l'ombre écrasante de
françois hollande dont je le rappelle
vous avez été ministre de la ville de la
jeunesse et des sports
troisième grande question de l'émission
le parlement est il menacé
d'affaiblissement est ce que vous
partagez en l'espèce l'inquiétude du
président larcher
voilà pour les trois grandes questions
mais d'abord une toute première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
alexis colère l'ex-secrétaire général de
l'elysée est l'objet on l'a appris
aujourd'hui d'une enquête s'est il
exposé dans le passé à des conflits
d'intérêts entre ses responsabilités
successives à bercy et ses liens
familiaux avec un armateur italien
soupçon totalement infondées dit
aujourd'hui l'elysée dont acte selon
vous non pas que vous de l'elysée le
parti financier en décidera
naturellement c'était important
ce n'est pas la limite le fond que je ne
connais pas de de ce dossier j'ai vu les
un ami de presse d'aujourd'hui
mais ce que l'erreur a l'occasion de se
défendre naturellement le parquet
financier poursuivra ou ne poursuivra
pas ce n'est pas bien sûr à moi de
commenter une telle hypothèse
ce que je vois simplement c'est que
aujourd'hui les questions de
transparence dans la vie politique
française les questions de probité les
questions finalement de d'être propre
avec la société sont prégnantes et moi
ça me va très bien
ça me va très bien après ce que nous
avons malheureusement voulait dire ce
qui m'a très bien c'est que c'est lent
que tout homme politique fait le soupçon
tout homme politique où tout responsable
politique auprès du président public en
l'occurrence et bien doit pouvoir et
savoir rendre des comptes quand cela est
née chez eux mais est-ce qu'il peut
rester en poste dans ces circonstances
on sait qu'une enquête parfois c'est
lourd y compris pour le principal
intéressé est ce qu'il peut rester
secrétaire général de l'elysée quand on
sait la responsabilité que ça implique
avec une enquête qui pèse sa tête comme
de vous dire que le pacte financier n'a
rien décidé pour l'instant
il y aussi parquet financier décidé
d'investiguer d'aller plus loin pourquoi
pas on pourrait se poser la question
mais à ce stade
vraiment là cette notion de présomption
d'innocence doit absolument être à
l'actif va que de monsieur koné clank
est l enquête du parquet vous avez
rappelé est nécessaire et les
nécessaires pour lever toute forme de
doute et saute pour permettre à mes
shows colère de s'expliquer s'il a
besoin de s'expliquer pour l'instant à
ce stade le sénateur que je suis
longtemps que je suis n'a que les
éléments de presse qui nous ont été
communiqués
c'est un métier mal avancé que malgré
tout le respect que je porte à la presse
cela n'est pas suffisant pour aller bien
sûr éléments de presse vous était ce
qu'il y a pas une affaire doivent plutôt
une opération dirigée directement contre
le président de la république a pas à
partir de son bras droit
aujourd'hui tout homme ou toute femme
qui est engagée dans le secteur public
dans la vie publique que c'est qu'il
peut être l'objet voilà deux d'attac
fait moi-même d'antan ministre j'ai fait
l'objet d'un louis et je vous le dis du
un recours devant la cour de justice de
la république pour des opérations de
marchés passés par le centre national du
ski j'étais je vous rassure totalement
laver mais voilà il faut accepter tout
ça en détail vous dites monsieur colère
a manqué de vigilance a quand même
en face d'une activité à l'at il été le
prix dont un prudent en tout cas il a
voulu travailler plusieurs fois sur la
société
l'armateur d'armateurs où il y aurait
semble-t-il des membres de sa famille
qui serait face à ferrer manifestement
tout ce qui s'est passé n'a pas été dans
la faveur d'ailleurs des intérêts
potentiels sa famille si j'ai bien
compris donc les sorcières le parent qui
fit tracteurs ils sont beaucoup plus à
même par noura moi même et que vous même
ça l'est plus mais la suite de l'épreuve
de vérité avec la question que vous vous
posez maintenant le site bréau
[Musique]
la première question elle est
d'actualité évidemment emmanuel macron
at-il selon vous remporter ce fameux
match sociale qui va lui permettre de
porter ces réformes déjà sur le plan
sémantique remporté un match et social
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il y aurait d'un côté
l'exécutif qui remporte sur les
syndicats ou sur les salariés
non je veux dire la france ne se
construit pas au travers de match
elle se construit travers de rapports de
force qui existe mais je vous en ai je
vous en une manche supplémentaire on
dira donc préféré était jésus bien
fondée sur la peur de roland garros
mais aujourd'hui tout d'abord ce conflit
n'est pas terminé
premièrement deuxième manche je me
satisfait de voir qu'au sénat des
avancées négociés par le syndicat
accompagnés par les parlementaires ont
permis de faire évoluer le texte qui
était sorti de l'assemblée nationale
j'ai bien lu que les syndicats
réformistes vont être claires l'unsa la
cfdt attendait cette fameuse commission
mixte paritaire pour savoir si ces
avancées allait être confirmée parce que
pour l'instant nous n'avons que les
engagements de la borne de convaincre
l'assemblée nationale encore faut-il
qu'elles puissent le faire je n'en doute
pas un seul instant
peut-être mais en tout cas attendant
cette cmp et nous verrons bien ce que
les syndicats réformistes et donc
monsieur macron apporter un texte qui
était et son gouvernement étaient je lui
dis mauvais il y a eu des avancées il ya
eu des prises de conscience la prise en
charge de l'aide de la dette à hauteur
de 35 milliards d'euros
un meilleur mais de meilleure sécurité
pour les pour les cheminots c'est grâce
à la rentrée avec la droite au sénat il
faut le dire que le texte s'est amélioré
et nous on fait notre travail aussi
renverrait le travail que vous avez voté
le texte sera présenté tel qu'il est
sorti de nos débats au groupe socialiste
et républicain et nous verrons quelle
sera la majorité du groupe sur cette
question alors le groupe réfléchit que
le texte n'est pas ni blanc ni noir il y
à des réflexions et votre votre vote il
sera blanc ou noir mais bien sûr mais
bon c'est moi je suis un sénateur parmi
d'autres et donc je respecterai la
majorité il sortira groupe demain matin
suspense encore donc si je fais et vous
appelez les syndicats à mettre fin au
mouvement social à partir du moment où
ce texte serait
à prouver on croit comprendre une rouge
à quel titre un politique demanderait un
syndicat de mettre fin ou de continuer
le mouvement social
non nous ne constatons pas une foudre
ton travail de parlementaire c'est aux
syndicats et notamment l'unsa la cgt qui
laisse entendre que de décider cela
après la cmp
après la cgt je crois veut maintenir la
pression parce qu'elle considère que
malgré les avancées et bien il n'y a pas
à négocier avec le gouvernement
ce que je vois c'est que quand même le
mouvement aujourd'hui s'essouffle
s'essouffle selon la formule consacrée
et que surtout les citoyens demandent
qu'on sorte par le haut avec la prise en
compte et pour moi majeur est ce qu'il y
a en france un service public de qualité
autour de la mobilité est d'ailleurs à
propos de ça j'aurais quand même aimé
que nous négocions une convention
collective de qualité sur les services
de la mobilité avant même de chercher le
statut des gens pour les pas nous dire
que c'est un succès qui se dessine pour
le président macro est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire que c'est un échec
pour mélenchon que nans chevaux est dans
une logique protestataires systématique
qu'il ne vise pas à gouverner
manifestement donc quelque part monsieur
mélenchon et
finalement donc pas un allié le mot
c'est trop fort mais en tout cas il sert
à à c'est la volonté du pont de la
république qui souhaite avoir d'un côté
une gauche extrême voilà avec des ad les
allant populiste une droite extrême et
on a vu avec notamment les prises de
position de monsieur wauquiez pour qu'il
y ait un extrême centre un extrême sans
plus y reviendrons sur le rôle du parti
socialiste bien sûr d'extrême centre
il veut l'incarner là je tiens beaucoup
d'argent on n'a pas réussi sa
mobilisation la convergence des luttes
qu'il appelait non parce qu'il n'a pas
mis la main sur tous les corps
intermédiaires on l'a bien vu avec la
cfdt et l'unsa
par contre je le dis au président de
république sachez respecter les corps
intermédiaires vous partage avons besoin
de cela dans notre pays mais lui il
raison vous l'avez entendu le chef de
l'état y est dit la démocratie sociale
c'est bien à l'intérieur de l'entreprise
mais les affaires de la nation c'est la
politique est ce que ce n'est pas une
réponse justement au renoncement du
passé le nom à la rue je crois tres tres
vraiment très franchement qu'aujourd'hui
plus que jamais puisqu'il ya une volonté
de réforme qui est manifeste
on a besoin de cette réforme soit
comprise fois admis soit accompagnée et
seuls les corps intermédiaires peuvent
le fun donc quand olivier faur votre
premier secrétaire dit emmanuel macron
radicalise le mouvement social vous êtes
d'accord avec lui vous êtes d'accord
avec ce constat qu'il fait voyez il est
clair que le texte qui est sorti de
l'assemblée nationale était un texte
presque de provocation par rapport à ce
que représente l'histoire de la sncf
l'histoire des cheminots dans notre pays
le travail du sénat a été je pense
fortement utile je verrais très
prochainement olivier faur auront
l'occasion d'en discuter
olivier faur fait son travail de premier
secrétaire quand il dit cela mais quand
on vous écoute on a l'impression que
c'est un bon texte qui sort du sénat qui
est un texte améliorée je n'ai pas dit
un bon texte un texte règle est amélioré
par rapport au texte initial du
gouvernement par rapport au texte qui
selon vous est ce aussi un terrain vous
avez lé texte de compromis
mais bien sûr un de compromis partager
c'est à dire qu' on ne peut pas gérer ce
pays comme une start up à coups de coups
de menton
il faut absolument que
les corps intermédiaires soient
respectés c'est la construction ce que
justement le lien n'est pas un peu rompu
entre le parti socialiste et les corps
intermédiaires puisqu'on a eu de manière
récurrente ces images du ps qui se fait
éjecter des manifestations enfin
notamment d'abord jeudi à cette gauche
extrême parce que c'est bien de cela
dont il s'agit qui a effectivement
obligé le premier secrétaire et ses
représentants j étais d'ailleurs pour la
manifestation du 22 mars à sortir du des
cortèges parce qu'il y avait des menaces
physiques sur nous jeudi c'est
inacceptable c'est intolérable et le ps
sera présent jeudi à un taudis à tous
que nous serons là pour défendre ce que
nous pensons être bon pour le pays et la
gauche extrême devra s'habituer à notre
présence les aides sociales
est-ce qu'il y en a trop d'entre eux
dans notre pays comme semblent le dire
le gouvernement je rappelle un chiffre
inouï la france consacre plus de 56% de
sa richesse à la dépense publique
majoritairement en dépenses sociales oui
enfin dans ce cadre là vous imitez aussi
la sécurité sociale les soins que vous
allez avoir peut-être monsieur grosseur
ou demain si vous êtes souffrent et
chaque chacun dit il ya trop de dépenses
sociales mais quand il peut en
bénéficier pour lui-même tout va bien
dans ces cas là la question qui est
posée c'est surtout les déclarations de
monsieur le maire monsieur darmanin
concernant les aides sociales liées à
l'emploi et là je dis attention danger
je ne veux pas qu'on touche à la prime
d'activité je ne veux pas qu'on touche à
la garantie jeunes pour les jeunes plus
en difficulté je ne veux pas qu'on
touche aux contrats aidés
toute une série de mesures que nous
avons porté accompagné des emplois
d'avenir aussi pour pour les jeunes et
je m'attarderai peut-être sur la prime
d'activité puisque manifestement elle
est dans le collimateur deux millions de
français en bénéficient
5 milliards d'euros de dépenses en 2017
jeu rapteur explose je rappelle quand
même qu'elle a remplacé un système qui
était totalement inefficients qu'on
appelait le rsa activité
vous avez oublié sûrement mais qui
existe est créée par nicolas sarkozy et
la fameuse ppe prime pour l'emploi
aujourd'hui cette prime d'activité est
un véritable déclencheur pour inciter à
l'emploi la remettre en cause serait une
erreur d'autant plus que cette prime qui
varient entre 100 et 150 euros suivant
les foyers n'est pas thésauriser elle
n'est pas mise sur un plan d'epargne en
actions elle est bien sûr quand on est
semi car elle est dépensé dans l'école
où les gens qui est réel travail à la
question
de notre sondage opinionway était celle
ci les aides sociales sont elles une
trappe à chômage est bien pour 55% des
français oui elle n'incite pas à
rechercher un emploi
oui aux travaux marcotte c'est pas comme
un chiffre je crois que les français
comprennent qu'on a besoin aussi et que
tout français a peut être dans une
difficulté un jour et sera très heureux
d'avoir des aides sociales qu'ils
éviteront la dérive dire que les
français recherchent le rsa si on
voulait pousser le raisonnement
l'extrême le rsa 550 euros grosso modo
par mois j'étais présent le conseil
général
je ne pense pas que les français du nord
je ne pense pas que les français
considèrent que l'aide sociale est une
solution la dignité passe par le travail
tout ce qui concourt à favoriser le
travail notamment le prénommé l'économie
se retournait en crée des emplois
j'en crée des emplois mais excusez moi
bureau sûr mais on crée des emplois
au jour d'aujourd'hui j'ai bien vu quand
même que les chiffres de la croissance
était quand même un peu plus restreint
l'année prochaine enfin à la fin d'année
2010 8 et encore plus en 2019 attention
danger
et là vous verrez que tout le monde
acceptera les aides sociales skis a pas
matière à réformer quand même quelque
part parce que vous mettez des verrous
très clair escape a quand même une
réflexion à avoir
toute réflexion est possible mais pour
l'instant ce que j'entends du
gouvernement c'est l'emploi va mieux et
donc on arrête pour être très précis
comme par hasard cette notion de remise
en cause des dépenses sociales liées à
l'emploi intervient à quel moment quand
on se demande comment on va financer la
taxe d'habitation qui va disparaître à
la fin de l'année 2020 déjà en partie en
2018 il ya la dette sncf qui arrive donc
si en fait les choix politiques du
gouvernement utilise comme variable
d'ajustement les aides sociales
vous verrez que ce pays va connaître une
grave difficulté et une grave un grave
et contentement pending grave colère
autre question du moment c'est le
logement vous mobiliser contre la
réforme des hlm modèle en danger lit-on
avec 2 milliards qui serait prélevé 1
chaque année mais le ministre julien des
nordiques étaient à votre place
ici même la semaine dernière monsieur
kenner affirme qu'il s'agit au contraire
de renforcer le modèle dont j'ai
aujourd'hui qui à près de deux millions
de personnes qui sont en attente d'un
logement social pour qu'est ce qu'on
fait on reste dans le statu quo ont fait
rien on transforme le modèle mais on le
fait de manière totalement responsable
c'est à dire que pour accompagner ces
bailleurs sociaux pour les accompagner
on met en face des investissements qui
sont très importants on leur permet
d'avoir accès à ce qu'on appelle les
financements de la caisse des dépôts de
manière totalement nouvelle
le idée ce sera mieux vaut vous dit ce
sera pire chez moi je crois qu'au
chiffre première éléments la baisse de
la paix elle n'est pas supportée
heureusement par l'usagé mais le
supporter par les bailleurs sociaux un
milliard et demi à supporter par les
bailleurs sociaux ça veut dire qu'il n'a
misé tirons pas pour autant notamment
dans les quartiers prioritaires de la
ville
même si aujourd'hui la politique de la
ville est extrêmement décriée par le
président de la république donc voilà un
exemple concret le réunir les bailleurs
sociaux qui seraient trop nombreux on
peut on peut l'évoquer ça peut être
intéressant mais si c'est pour aboutir à
ce que la loi est lent prévoit à savoir
une diminution du nombre d'appartements
propriété ses bailleurs sociaux parce
qu'on est vendrait pour mieux
reconstruire nous étions là encore oui
j'attends de voir j'attends de voir ce
que je constate c'est que si on vend des
logements dans les quartiers
prioritaires où dans certaines villes
qui ne respectent pas leurs engagements
par rapport à la fameuse loi sru
eh bien on renforcera la ségrégation
sociale l'égoïsme territoriales donc je
pense que le gouvernement a un double
langage sur cette question nous aurons
l'occasion de le dire au sénat et vous
savez que les députés socialistes ont
mené la bataille il ya encore ce
week-end
deuxième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant avec stéphanie les rouges qui
va vous poser la question de famille
donc de ces partis sur le ps dont on se
demande s'il peut renaître avec son
nouveau premier secrétaire et à l'ombre
de françois hollande qui est très
présente dans le débat public depuis
quelques semaines renaître pourquoi nous
ne sommes pas morts
bah on se pose la question
à est-ce que nous sommes passés de la
réanimation en soins intensifs en
passant par un peu la convalescence
c'est vrai que nous sommes en difficulté
si je vous disais le contraire vous
pourriez sourire et à juste titre donc
sans difficulté mais nous avons encore
beaucoup de ressort vous êtes dans vos
un sénateur qui a été bien élu par ses
grands électeurs nous avons encore
beaucoup de collectivités territoriales
nous avons encore qu'on le veuille ou
non
cinquante soixante mille militants qui
sont là nous avons aussi des des
sympathisants qui nous disent mais nous
on a voté pour manier le maquereau
second tour voire même au premier tour
et qui se disent mais le compte n'y est
pas et que le niveau partager cette
pensée ah oui je partage très léger rien
regretter écoutez vous avez déjà une
vingtaine de députés en marche qui
s'exprimeraient bientôt dans une tribune
pour dire attention il faut que la
gauche de des remarques des marcheurs
soit respectée je ne sais pas si elle
sera respectée mais en tout cas il y a
non pas un vent de fronde oui à quoi je
peux faire allusion mais il ya un vent
de d'interrogations chez des élus dans
marche qu'ils ont pu avoir un parcours
socialiste historiquement il y en a
quand même beaucoup ou même des
électeurs qui n'ont pas voté amont pour
être très clair au premier tour des
élections présidentielles il ya
maintenant un peu plus d'un an et qui se
disent mais qu'est ce qu'on a devant
nous est-ce qu'il ya pas une remise en
cause finalement de ce triptyque voulue
par le pronom république je répète
libéré protéger unir
on a plutôt aujourd'hui libéré que le
reste est donc le parti socialiste ne se
construira pas en creux des déceptions
je suis totalement clair sur le sujet on
se construira sur un projet politique
que nous devons porter comme étant une
véritable alternative
lacroix construire avec françois
hollande je repose ma question d'autant
qu'il sera la fondation jean jaurès
jeudi le 7 juin pour un débat où il va
faire l'inventaire de son propre cachet
d'ailleurs je n'y serai pas
malheureusement pas ce que je serais à
la même heure sur la tombe de pierre
mauroy et nous allons célébrer le
cinquième anniversaire disparition de
pierre mauroy qui était vous le savez on
m en politique à lille françois hollande
a toute sa place dans un dispositif
socialiste il est socialiste
aujourd'hui ce qu'il fait et nous l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises y compris en
privé ou en public c'est je défends le
bilan que personne a défendu mais ce qui
est bon dans l'allemagne presque trop
des fois quitte à en devenir presque
j'ai le sentiment que vous avez bien
quand il parle vous n'invitez souvent
sur les plateaux dans les radios parce
qu'il parle bien parce qu'il parle juste
parce qu'il aime
voilà être au contact des français ont
été taguées dans l'entreprise du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui on va construire
en tout cas françois hollande ne veut
pas être un obstacle mais vous vous
accompagne at her say he continuer votre
allié dans cette phase là aujourd'hui je
pense qu on ne construira pas un parti
socialiste sans françois hollande sans
le respect du bilan dans ces phases
positives et la part d'une personne
maintenance en colombie mais qui pouvait
ramener le parti socialiste sur gautier
rolland qui peut mieux incarner
aujourd'hui le bilan du quinquennat
sinon le président d'un public qui en
était le responsable
voilà donc le il en est elle qui n'a pas
pu se représenter oui c'est un
formidable malentendu ça j'espère qu'un
jour on l'analysera pour moi moi je
souhaitais et françois hollande se
représente je souhaitais même qu'il
n'aille pas aux primaires je vous dis
très simplement et qu'ils puissent
défendre son bilan et l'histoire on
aurait été sûrement différente donc qui
ait pas de malentendu là non plus
françois hollande n'est pas candidat
pour 2022
et d'ailleurs même si l'été ne vous
dirai pas si vous n'avez ce qu'il veut
simplement on a des camps d'été en 2020
et que bien sûr oui bien sûr il dit qu
il est là pour d'abord défendre son
bilan à ce stade
aujourd'hui le président de la
république françois hollande sortant a
envie d'être respectée sur le travail
qu'il a fait pour la france et les
français et moi
dix jeux mais c'est trop tôt je ne sais
pas si c'est trop tôt ou trop tard je
dis simplement que ce travail de
conviction qui est en train de porter et
de pédagogie mérite là aussi de notre
part une grande attention
y compris de la part des responsables
socialistes ce n'est pas contre le parti
socialiste
c'est un élément d'accompagnement de
cette renaissance voulue par olivier
forme et donc il ne sera pas encombrant
comme pourrait le craindre certains
jusqu'à être candidat ou candidat à la
candidature en 2022 live vous l'a dit
qui peut aujourd'hui penser qu'un
socialiste raisonnablement structure et
peut déjà se porter candidat pour 2022
saluant une grande peur étapes d'abord
les européennes
on va en parler l'élection du candidat
aujourd'hui ce qui veut pas dire qu'il
ne sera pas demain mais il a dit lui
mais bien sûr mais mais enfin comment
voulez-vous il n'exclut rien mais c'est
comme si je vous disais pas moi ça
m'intéresse d'être condamné en 2022 mais
ce serait absurde absurde créé françois
olivier faure a pas dit qu'il y aurait
une primaire à nouveau en 2022 ça sera
pas une primaire ouverte comme jusqu'à
présent sera une privée en primaire sur
un périmètre un peu plus restreint et
ski si hollande françois hollande devait
être candidat ce qu'il faudrait qu'ils
passent par cette primaire puisque vous
me disiez que vous êtes vraiment
une pointe de déception de plus vous
avez raison nous interroger il y aura
une primaire pour désigner notre
candidat
je souhaite effectivement qui n'est pas
une primaire ouverte large parce que
finalement ceux qui sont venus voter à
la primaire
en janvier 2017
on fait des choix contre non pas des
choix pour bâtiments communs que vous
avez évoqué les rendez-vous des
européennes des municipales en parler
maintenant
justement donc avant 2022 évidemment il
ya les européennes qui approche alors
les communistes ont désigné leur tête de
liste ce week-end ils ont choisi ian
brossât la question elle se pose à vous
maintenant qui doit être le candidat du
parti socialiste pierre moscovici ce
serait un bon choix par exemple je peux
pierre moscovici a déclaré sa
candidature une réponse est non il a
fait une très belle prestation au
congrès est-ce que vous soyez dans un
candidat est-ce que vous souhaitez qu'il
a il a ressorti le mans candidats
dites nous quel est votre candidat moi
je m'étais exprimé olivier parmi la dig
il a dit non non non je me chiffre est
historiquement dix ans mais j'aurais
bien voulu via la boutique et najat
vallaud belkacem pierre moscovici
voilà déjà lequel c'est ma priorité
n'est pas intéressée puisque ici
peut-être les plus qu'elle ne l'est elle
même il a le profil
il a les compétences ben oui vous les b
et c'est un ancien ministre il a été
député il a été responsable politique et
donc il n'est pas plus légitime
permettez moi l'expression que quelqu'un
londres au contraire donc mais c'est aux
militants socialistes d'en décider
ils le feront à l'automne mais d'abord
sur un projet bâti sont d'abord notre
projet politique et nous verrons qui est
le mieux placé pour le défendre
j'ai bien entendu cette hypothèse si
personne n'est mieux placé c'est le rôle
du premier secrétaire aux vielles fort a
priori n'ai pas envie de faire cela donc
rassurez vous il y aura un candidat et
il y aura une liste ou une candidate
on attendra concernant les municipales
on sait qu'en marche recrute 1 puisque
le parti présidentiel est prêt à des
accords on va écouter christophe carte
ce questionnaire qui était sur public
sénat et qui explique qu'en marche donc
est prêt à des accords à gauche comme à
droite il ya des endroits où vous avez
des maires élus par le avec une
étiquette du parti socialiste avec une
étiquette tlr qu'on fait un super boulot
je n'exclus rien et je les dis à tous
les marcheurs vous faites d'abord un
diagnostic de situation vous allez à la
rencontre des habitants vous sentez la
perception est ce que ce maire joue le
jeu de la démocratie
est-ce que ce maire a transformé sa
ville si c'est le cas je me fiche de
savoir s'il a été un jour républicain ou
pas je lui ferai une proposition de
travail
je proposerai un socle de valeurs
communes un engagement commun jeu
demandera des marcheurs de l'accompagner
si le maire le souhaite et je pourrais
parfaitement soutenir le jeu étant la
république en marche se tenir à mr
quelle que soit l'origine de son
engagement
alors comment est ce que vous réagissez
à ce positionnement très mal c'est à
dire très mal le bon docteur castaner
donne des certificats des diagnostics
aux uns aux autres mais si en marche a
envie d'exister son plan territorial
mais qu'ils se comptent qu'ils se
présentent sur leur éthique vire et ça
c'est bien
je suis toujours en train de chercher là
la colonne vertébrale idéologique dans
marche ni droite ni gauche mais c'est
pas une colonne vertébrale idéologique
il y a des gîtes des maires de droite là
des maires de gauche dans ce pays il ya
des mères aussi non inscrits dans et
pendant les petites communes mais là
manifestement ce qui est intéressant
marché avec en lever une grande les
grandes villes mais messi en marche est
un projet politique municipale ben voilà
qu'il se présente qu'ils se comptent moi
j'ai aucun aucun problème mais cette
idée de donner des bons points des
mauvais points je te ferai roi je te
ferai plus rien tu es mon sujet enfin
c'est une suffisance une arrogance moi
qui qui m'exaspère qui correspond aussi
un peu ce qui se passe au niveau
national
vous savez les sénatoriales ont été un
bon signe en la matière monsieur patriat
espérait 70 80 il menace même d'un
scrutin non plus c'est pas même mode de
scrutin mais les sénateurs en marche
sont moins nombreux depuis la dernière
élection c'est à dire que les grands
électeurs n'ont pas choisi en marche
si monsieur castetner exister
territorialement en tant que chef de
parti c'est pas le ministre que
j'interpelle c'est le chef de parti et
bien qu'il aille jusqu'au bout qu'ils
présentent des listes en marche et c'est
vrai que dans une municipale une liste
d'une alchimie
il ya de tout dans une liste et nous
verrons bien ce qui est le plus apprécié
par les électeurs ou plan d'accord pour
locale vous refusé sa main tendue est ce
que vous n'imaginez donc pas passer des
accords effectivement avec la république
en marche que par ailleurs vous
combattez aux niveaux nationaux mais
encore une fois la version l'expression
d'alchimie il peut y avoir sur un projet
politique locale des alliances
politiques par exemple pour éviter que
le front national met la main sur une
ville
tout ceci est possible mais dans la
clarté et là j'ai l'impression que
monsieur castetner est plutôt dans la
dans la tuyauterie dans l'échafaudage
de d'accords locaux je veux dire à la
discrétion des uns et des autres ça fait
peur que certains de vos camarades
socialistes disent banco était de sauver
leur tête en tourner un lien avec la
république en a en tout cas c'est de
l'ancien monde tout ça c'est du très
très ancien monde
ces petits type d'accord que cherche
monsieur castaner on entend souvent
votre nom revenir pour la mairie de
lille alors on ne sait pas encore si
martine aubry ce que ce que ce qu'elle
en pense en tout cas aujourd'hui une
réflexion est ce que vous pourriez être
candidat mais je me prépare je me
prépare je juge très bien ici au sénat
et il vous aura pas échappé que le cumul
des mandats était impossible entre un
mandat parlementaire les mandats
exécutifs locale encore faut-il qu'on
soit you plan local naturellement moi je
me prépare je réfléchis que ce qui
intéresse ma ville m'intéresse c'est
vrai que beaucoup de lillois viennent me
voir spontanément de différentes
sensibilités en pensant que voilà je
suis quelqu'un de respecté de
respectables diront certains mais moi je
souhaite en parler bien sûr d'abord avec
la principale intéressée qui est martine
aubry se prépare qui elle-même doit se
voit là doit s'opérer question vous avez
martine aubry avait dit à mon dernier
mandat s'étend au delà il ya un problème
sa photo pour nous un fauteuil pour
personne il faut une primaire qu un free
présente dans le sens où une élection
n'est jamais gagnée d'avancé
et en tout cas ce que je sais c'est que
la division serait mortifère mortifère
et que donc c'est sur un projet
politique que nous devons nous mettre
d'accord moi même encore une fois je
réfléchis d'abord sur le projet et nous
verrons bien si je suis le mieux à même
de pouvoir le porter mais on ne peut pas
se faire entre guillemets dans
l'éviction des uns ou des autres se
faire dans la concertation et je le dis
ici sur votre plateau si martine aubry
souhaite me rencontrer pour évoquer ces
questions pour préparer l'avenir de
l'île et surtout éviter que cet objet
froid si fort pour nous en terme de
symbole de bascule
à droite ou au centre droit emmené le
département comme le département et nous
avons fait beaucoup d'erreurs qui nous
ont amenés malheureusement père le
départ vous avez rappelé la longévité
municipal de martine aubry où dit il
faut aussi une alternance mais certaine
manière la même dans la même étiquette
écoutez c'est martine aubry elle-même
qui l'a qu'il a évoquée en disant 2014
ce sera mon dernier mandat
elle ne le dit plus je peux le
comprendre la succession qu'elle avait
imaginé se passe pas comme elle le
souhaiterait manifestement donc
discutons-en nous sommes voilà donc va
falloir l'agent elle n'est pas facile à
convaincre un avc a voulu poser la
question hier question peut-être sur le
parti socialiste
qu'est ce que vous pensez de son
déménagement à priori à evry dans la
banlieue rouge
je me suis exprimé j'ai étais pas
favorable je préférerais rester sur sur
paris mais si le parti le décide il le
fera manifestement à son conseil
national de samedi prochain
voilà ce sera ma aussi ma décision que
j'avais bien un vieux militant parce que
je t'aime pour des raisons matérielles
je pense que c'est plus simple pour les
militants qui viennent de province de se
retrouver dans paris et ne pas reprendre
des moyens de transport pour ensuite
descendre jure sur un gain symbolique
aussi est ce que c'est les lieux du
pouvoir
le symbole d'être sur paris moi j'aurais
aimé par exemple qu'on soit sur un
arrondissement dans le nord de paris
d'un arrondissement populaire et pas
automatiquement en achetant mais en
sachant loup et voilà allez faut savoir
dessiner sur le marché immobilier
parisien troisième partie de l'effort de
vérité maintenant avec la question que
va vous poser lucille
[Musique]
cette troisième question elle vous
concerne à plus d'un titre parce que
vous êtes le patron du groupe socialiste
au sénat alors le parlement est il
menacé aujourd'hui d'affaiblissement
quand on connaît la nature des réformes
institutionnelles qui sont en cours qui
sont prévues par le gouvernement menace
mot peut permettre fort et pourtant
c'est le bon bout c'est le bien une
menace aujourd'hui c'est la première
fois depuis 1962 et cet acte majeur qui
a consisté à faire élire le suffrage
universel direct le président de la
république sa première fois que le
parlement se voir retirer
potentiellement des pouvoirs
jusqu'à présent ça a toujours été dans
le sens inverse on à rééquilibrer au
profit du législatif vielle l'acte
initial qui avait été celui de du
général de gaulle sur cette notion de
parlementarisme rationnalisé même
nicolas sarkozy
disons le à donner plus de pouvoir au
parlement notamment permettant ces
fameux fameuse semaine de débats
parlementaires
avec un ordre du jour maîtrisiens c'est
ce que vous dites mais il ya un recul la
volonté d'aller vite et respectable mais
ne peut pas se faire au détriment du
travail parlementaire de il faut du
temps il faut que le parlement ait du
temps pour bien travailler et quand je
vois l'accumulation des lots texte de
loi qui arrive je dis qu'on nous ne
sommes pas assez respecté un exemple
très concret même si aujourd'hui il a
été écarté et heureusement imaginez osé
imaginer
même si c'est dans un document de
travail que j'ai reçues quand j'ai été
rencontrés avec olivier soir à l'époque
président du moufia liste de l'assemblée
nationale monsieur premier ministre
imaginez qu'on peut limiter le nombre
d'amendements en fonction de la taille
du groupe
ce n'est plus de réformes je vous
conseille mais l'avoir imaginé l'avoir
écrit est un acte qui montre que quelque
part on ne comprend pas la place du
parlement
et il yad'autres choses aujourd'hui dans
les textes qui nous inquiète beaucoup je
pense notamment à la maîtrise de l'ordre
du jour qui reviendrait 2,7 à nouveau au
gouvernement il ya quand même une
volonté de rationaliser le travail sur
les amendements
d'aller plus vite d'optimiser le travail
parlementaire on se demande est ce que
ces anti parlementariste où il ya une
attente de l'opinion très simplement qui
attend aussi de la modernité ça
passerait aussi vous écouter l'opinion
elle peut être très contradictoires elle
dira mais moi je veux voir mon député
régulièrement et c est en même temps à
battre au député aïda programmateur
c'est très une forme de schizophrénie en
la matière et je trouve que le point de
la république y compris par la baisse de
nos parlementaires va dans ce sens ce
n'est pas en présentant le scalp de 30%
des parlementaires qu'on fera améliorer
le fonctionnement de notre démocratie il
faut accepter un équilibre entre pouvoir
exécutif qui va être fort et un
parlement qui doit avoir des pouvoirs
reconnus et équilibrée finalement le
fonctionnement de notre république
alors sur ce sujet toutes ces questions
il ya une voix forte qui s'exprime c'est
celle du président du sénat gérard
larcher en les côtes menaçant et
déterminé ce ne sera jamais au détriment
des droits du parlement et de la
démocratie représentative et cela n'est
pas négociable
comme ça c'est clair c'est dit pourriez
dire la même chose mais c'est que oui
tout à fait on entend toujours pas les
mêmes sanctions politiques mais sur la
place du parlement dans la république
dans la vème république il ya là un
véritable consensus qui dépasse
largement largement les sensibilités
politiques des groupes tant mieux tant
mieux on se demande un petit peu si les
parlementaires ne devrait pas se
corriger eux mêmes on a vu beaucoup
cette question revenir ces derniers
temps la semaine dernière
particulièrement parfois est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que l'affluence des
lobbys est trop forte ya une loi ça
paraît un peu qui essayait de l'encadrer
sa loi ça ça n'a pas l'air d'être
suffisant le en l'espèce l'encadrement
existe les lobbys doivent se déclarer
dans un fichier etc
mais on n'a pas interdit le lobbying il
est encadré je reprends votre expression
et d'ailleurs en europe ne des succès
vous le reconnaissez notamment sur
effectivement la loi alimentation avec
par exemple le débat sur le glyphosate
ya également les caméras dans les
abattoirs ou encore les techdays
nutritionnelle g6 et des lobbyistes sais
qu'il ya des gens qui sont sensibles au
but
et donc dans ces cas là il faut savoir
si on est prêt à résister ou pas vous
gérez hommage de manière individuelle et
collective individuelle comme sénateur
mais collective dont deux du groupe
nous sommes extrêmement vigilants et
nous n'allons pas parler mais
l'expression des choses que nous voulons
pas avaler quand la cfdt vient nous voir
en disant mais voilà un bel à un travail
de lobbying influence quand ils viennent
nous voir pour évoquer l'amélioration du
texte sur la sncf
et quand ça nous semble être allé dans
le bon sens nous sommes capables d'avoir
une distinction d'avoir un jugement en
conscience sur ce qu'il faut faire si
appris les intérêts financiers
ça pose d'autres d'occulter tout cas le
lobby continue à exister il est encadré
la hausse atteint 2 a vraiment permis
d'éviter toutes ses formes d'abus après
elle est très récente c'est toi en 2017
prenons le recul pour vérifier que
qu'elle s'applique dans de bonnes
conditions tragiques à cette question
nous amène à la dimension écologique du
gouvernement vous allez pouvoir vous
exprimer là dessus c'était le thème de
notre seconde question du sondage
opinionway pour l'épreuve de vérité est
ce que nicolas hulot selon vous doit
rester ou pas au gouvernement
partir pour 52% des français et vous à
une sacrée force de résilience vous
permettez l'expression
dre complément certains diront qu'il est
qu il avalé beaucoup de couleuvres
un homme que j'ai pu croiser quelques
fois quand j'étais ministre
c'est un homme de qualité je crois
profondément sincère et intègre
il est solidaire du gouvernement c'est
pas un ancien ministre qui vous dira de
ne pas être solidaire du gouvernement
après la question cette solidarité ira
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat on peut on
peut en douter
mais prenons un exemple très concret il
a préservé la loi littoral
manifestement dans le débat sur cette
vie de la rúa que vous mettez à son
crédit ah oui total bourg main et
et il faut le il faut le reconnaître ils
étaient remises à certains aspects
étaient remises en cause mon logement
exactement pour notamment construire
dans les dents creuses le long du real
il s'est battu
nous l'avons nous mêmes accompagnés et
donc cette sincérité la part dont
d'accord faut savoir y ait quelqu'un
d'autre que vous avez beaucoup croisé
dans votre vie récente c'est emmanuel
macron et on a envie de vous poser des
questions sur lui à travers votre regard
votre pratique étiez à la table du
conseil des ministres avec lui vous avez
partagé d'exercer mon voisin de table
qui plus est quel regard vous portez
vous quelle image vous gardé depuis
ministre un ministre extrêmement
brillant dont les analyses sur le plan
économique était très largement partagée
apprécié au conseil des ministres
voilà il a été un ministre
loyal fidèle et respectant le cap fixé
par le président de de la république
loyal et fidèle on entend rarement ça
dans la bouche des socialistes alors là
vous nous et fhp reparler d'un ministre
loyal et fidèle
il n'est pas resté il n'est pas resté
ministre ne vais pas rester loyal
univers restent minimes et loyal et
fidèle
ça vous que si vous êtes françois
hollande il est clair qu'ils considèrent
que la fidélité loyauté n'ont pas été
toujours au rendez vous ben vous voyez
pas l'air de lui en tenir rigueur
oh je sais mais moi je ne fais pas de
politique en regardant dans le
rétroviseur
monsieur macron a fait un choix il a été
très loin dans ce choix il aurait pu en
faire d'autres
il a gagné il a gagné
j'ai souvent cette image vis-à-vis de
lui de deux joueurs de monopoly qui
passe de la case départ la rue de la
paix à faire passer par les cases
intermédiaire il a gagné et il a gagné
maintenant il doit transformer cette
gagne électorale il le fait depuis un an
en réalité est là permettez moi d'être
en divergence avec nombre de ces mesures
pour moi ne sont pas vraies ne sont pas
équilibrés emmanuel macron s'était aussi
fait connaître et apprécier parce qu'ils
avaient
défendu pied à pied sa loi devant les
députés en passant des heures à défendre
chaque amendement et c'est donc c'est un
ministre qui était à l'époque
extrêmement respectueux du parlement et
qui se sent de sept converties en
jupiter dans une pratique beaucoup plus
verticale du pouvoir comment vous
comprenez cette conversion ne suis pas
dans la tête de monsieur mâcon il a
changé de rôle de rôle de ministre dans
un collectif pour mettre en place une
politique voulue par le président de
république et le premier ministre
il est passé un rôle de décideur et si
sa personnalité s'affirme aujourd'hui
comme celle de jupiter pour reprendre
l'expression certains diront de
bonaparte ou où napoléon il ya c'est
vrai une logique très verticale
aujourd'hui et sûrement parce que étant
très jeune
finalement à 40 ans des 39 ans d'une
première publique il n'a pas cette
expérience que qu'ont pu avoir ses
prédécesseurs notamment sur le plan
local bien sûr donc en tous les cas on
va pas encore parler de françois
hollande parce que vous en avez marre
vous l'avez dit on veut peut citer que
ceux ci prennent ma foi j'ai pas mal
voyagé pas marre de france on en parlait
peut-être avec nous en tous les cas et
christian eckert qui était ministre
aussi avec voulu il a écrit un livre où
il exprime sa rancoeur vis-à-vis des
manuels ma ministre ne veut pas dire ça
ah oui c'est pas encore lu donc à bombay
et dit que
macron il a un algorithme à la place du
coeur vous n'avez pas de rancoeur dans
les cas c'est quand c'est ce qu'on
constate monsieur le ministre des sports
va terminer sur vos anciennes fonctions
avec cette question de lucile puis en
service des sports du coup vous avez été
attentifs aux droits du foot on l
imagine c'est un opérateur étranger
mediapro en partie contrôlé par des
chinois qui a décroché la timbale canal
plus n'a rien gros scandale
un peu de protectionnisme dans ce
domaine selon vous oui d'autant plus
qu'on n'est pas certain de viabilité
financière de mediapro moi je regrette
pour canal plus c'est que c'est une
chaîne française
l'argent est partout dans ce sport de
haut niveau je ne sais pas si je dois le
regretter je le constate en tant que tel
on a essayé de mettre en place du fair
play notamment sur les transferts au
niveau des joueurs pour éviter les abus
et que finalement une équipe en porte
mais vous avez bien vu avec le paris
saint-germain que c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui le paris saint-germain
écrase le reste de la ligue 1 on pourra
dire autrement
donc c'est devenu un spectacle c'est le
sait les quilles o qu'il est dit
aujourd'hui dans un grand journal c'est
devenu un spectacle et donc ça dérègle
des spectacles peut-on l'en empêcher je
ne crois pas par contre ce qu'il faut
c'est équilibré avec les recettes cet
argent pour que le sport amateur puisse
se développer que les jeunes puissent
rhin et le ruissellement le
ruissellement appliquée alors
aujourd'hui je ne rêve pas au
ruissellement jeu le plus je crois à la
volonté politique qui permette d'aboutir
aux résultats
merci beaucoup monsieur canard d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui merci à vous
deux et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]